salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique aujourd'hui nous
sommes le 14 juillet 2021 et entre les
absences de feux d'artifice les
annulations de diverses festivités et la
pluie vous vous dites certainement que
ce 14 juillet est le plus pourri que
l'on ait connu et bien détrompez vous le
pire des 14 juillet est et restera à
jamais le 14 juillet 1989
ce 14 juillet a été tellement horrible
qu'il a été oblitérées de la mémoire
collective et qu'on en trouve uniquement
quelques traces ici et là comme par
exemple une allusion dans un sketch des
inconnus sur la révolution française ont
dû adapter moi même enfin alors si vous
les adaptez à votre tour qu'est ce que
ça va devenir n'importe quoi du jean
paul goude
enfin alors pourquoi ce 14 juillet at il
été aussi horrible eh bien il faut se
mettre dans le contexte nous sommes donc
en 1989
c'est à dire l'année du bicentenaire de
la révolution française et pour marquer
le coup
le gouvernement dirigé par françois
mitterrand décide d'organiser de
nombreux événements en l'honneur de
cette date
par exemple alors que j'étais élève de
maternelle j'avais été déguisés en
petits sans culotte avec tous les petits
camarades et nous étions elle est
commémoré le massacre d horribles
vendéen contre-révolutionnaires au
niveau national également il y avait eu
un téléfilm en trois parties qui a été
financée par l'état avec même des têtes
d'affiché internationales
et puis surtout le 14 juillet devait
marquer l'apogée de ces commémorations
du bicentenaire de la révolution
en plus des festivités classique le
gouvernement avait décidé d'organiser
une grande parade le soir du 14 juillet
sur les champs elysées pour cela ils ont
fait appel à jean paul goude l'individu
cité par bernard campan le sketch des
inconnus pour organiser la dite parade
qui devait s'appeler la marseillaise
alors jean paul goude n'est pas un
politique ce n'est pas non plus un
historien
c'est un publicitaire c'est quelqu'un
qui crée des clips pour des marques qui
lançait des produits etc mais n'est pas
du tout familier des grands spectacles
historiques a surtout à forte charge
politique en l'occurrence comme les
théoriquement une parade
rappelant le bicentenaire de la
révolution française et c'est donc
un spectacle totalement aberrant auquel
les français vont assister ce 14 juillet
1989 et je vous propose est bien de voir
cela en images
ce défilé est constitué d'une douzaine
de tableaux censé représenter des tribus
planétaire même si on ne voit pas bien
le rapport avec la révolution française
le premier tableau qui est probablement
le plus le plus sobre et le plus
politique représente la chine avec un
tambour géants et des chinois qui marche
autour avec des vélos parce que bien sûr
les chinoises efface tous à vélo c'est
une constante dans ce défilé
on joue en permanence avec les
stéréotypes culturels un peu raciste en
théorie pour les subvertir et les
détourner en fait à la base dans ce
tableau il devait y avoir des gardes
rouges chinois qui devaient danser le
breakdance mais le 14 juillet 89 lieu
quelques semaines après les événements
de tiananmen au cours duquel le régime
chinois a écrasés au sens propre comme
au figuré à l'opposition il a été décidé
de faire quelque chose de plus sobre que
des soldats chinois dans son paquet
mais rassurez vous après ce petit
passage politique
on referme la parenthèse et on ne
gardera que l'aberration dans le reste
du défilé
vous avez ensuite plusieurs cortèges
avec notamment des instruments de
musique et surtout des tambours puisque
jean paul goude estimé que la vraie
révolution serait l'apparition d'une
sonorité mondiale et du coup les
tambours sont omniprésents dans le
défier on a aussi un cortège africain
composé de percussionnistes avec un chef
d'orchestre un célèbre percussionniste
sénégalais ce cortège étant entouré de
soldats en uniforme coloniale donc là
encore on a lu l'un des aspects
récurrents de son défilé à savoir le
mélange de différentes histoires nées à
la colonisation pour donner est de
gloubiboulga où tout le monde est
heureux où les cultures se mélangent
s'il me semble personnellement que la
colonisation a été quelque chose d'un
petit peu plus compliqué que ça
[Musique]
vous allez également avoir une
cantatrice américaine qui va chanter la
marseillaise
alors personnellement quand je pense
cantatrice et marseillaise je pense
plutôt à papy fait de la résistance
[Musique]
oz à ce jeu tu assistes d'une
marseillaise qui n'a mais bon on a
chacun nos référents culturels
on a aussi une thématique britannique
puisqu'on a des bus à impériale avec des
personnes qui tiennent des parapluies
parce qu'on sait tous il pleut en
permanence en angleterre et d'ailleurs à
un moment les pompiers qui les
accompagnent vont arroser les
participants avec une pluie artificielle
dans ce cortège vous avez aussi des
danseuses indiennes et pakistanaises
donc là encore un mélange de l'histoire
coloniale avec la culture est également
dans ce cortège au départ il devait y
avoir des éléphants mais ils ont été
plus futé que les humains qui les
accompagnaient sont vus sortir le truc
et ils étaient tous malades et n'ont pas
pu participer au défilé
et puis vous avez parmi les derniers
cortèges un tableau soviétique avec des
membres de l'armée rouge et un ours
polaire qui fait du patin à glace
alors bien sûr on voit tous le rapport
entre les soviétiques et les principes
de la révolution française liberté
égalité fraternité des mots qui ont tous
été enterrés dans le sang par la
révolution soviétique et enfin pour
clôturer ce défilé du 14 juillet dont la
thématique était il faut le rappeler
parce que des fois qu'on nous dit un
petit peu la révolution française on a
droit à un marché une bande d'étudiants
américains qui vont nous faire des
reprises de james bond et de michael
jackson
et ce spectacle durera au total trois
heures de 21h30 à 00h30
il sera vu sur les champs elysées par un
million de spectateurs et sera
retransmis sur deux chaînes publiques de
l'époque tf1 et antenne 2 tf1 choisir à
léon zitrone grands présentateurs de
l'époque connu de tous pour commenter le
défilé et ce pauvre lyon si tron n'a pas
été très fan de la parade et avec
quelques commentaires un petit peu blasé
et n'a pas bien compris en fait ce
qu'ils voyaient devant lui quand n 2 a
choisi de journalistes plutôt de gauche
claude sérillon et frédéric mitterrand
donc le neveu du monarque pour commenter
cette parade eux par contre vont se
livrer à des interprétations regard des
surinterprétations pour essayer de faire
coller les images
avec la thématique officiel de la soirée
mais c'est peine perdue puisque dès le
lendemain jean paul goude dans une
interview expliquera que ben en fin de
compte ils savaient pas forcément quoi
faire en lien avec la révolution
française et qu'il a fait un petit peu
un petit peu au pif et de fait cette
parade après semblait à une sorte de
parade de disneyland ou une parade un
peu kitsch un train l'ouverture des jeux
olympiques
mais quand on confie ce genre de choses
hautement symbolique un publicitaire
faut pas non plus s'attendre à des
miracles
bref c'est cette vidéo vous a fait
relativiser la catastrophe que peut être
ce 14 juillet 2021 et bien n'hésitez pas
à partager cette vidéo pour traumatiser
vos proches après tout les pas de raison
est également bien abonnez-vous à la
chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait et sur
ce jeudi à la prochaine